.
GAYLE?
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
SAYS IT IS MAKING PROGRESS AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER WHERE THE
NUMBER OF UNACCOMPANIED MIGRANT
CHILDREN IN CUSTODY HAS FALLEN
DRAMATICALLY.
HOMELAND SECURITY OFFICIALS SAY
U.S. CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION HELD 677 CHILDREN
OVER THE WEEKEND.
NOW THAT IS AN 88% DROP FROM
MARCH WHEN THE AGENCY HAD A
RECORD 5,700 LONE MINORS IN
CUSTODY.
THE DHS SECRETARY, ALEJANDRO
MAYORKAS, JOINS US FIRST ON "CBS
THIS MORNING."
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, MR.
SECRETARY.
>> GOOD MORNING.
PLEASURE TO BE HERE.
THANK YOU.
>> WE'RE GLAD YOU'RE HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO GET TO THE
NUMBERS IN A SECOND.
FIRST, WE WANT TO START WITH THE
STORY THAT LILLIANA JUST
REPORTED ABOUT THE -- IT APPEARS
TO BE A CASE OF HUMAN SMUGGLING.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED HERE?
>> WE ARE INTERDICTING
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE TRAFFICKED
BY HUMAN SMUGGLERS BOTH ON LAND
AND AT SEA.
AND IT IS A POWERFUL AND
UNFORTUNATELY TRAGIC EXAMPLE OF
THE MANNER IN WHICH HUMAN
SMUGGLERS EXPLOIT VULNERABLE
INDIVIDUALS.
IT IS WHY WE SO OFTEN AND SO
POWERFULLY ARTICULATE THAT ONE
SHOULD NOT TAKE THE DANGEROUS
JOURNEY.
WE ARE BUILDING LAWFUL PATHWAYS
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO ACCESS OUR
ASYLUM SYSTEM AS THE LAW
PROVIDES.
A TRAGIC EXAMPLE OF WHAT HUMAN
SMUGGLERS DO TO PEOPLE IN NEED.
>> IT IS TRAGIC.
I HEAR YOU SAY, LOOK, WE TELL
PEOPLE DON'T COME, BUT THEY
CONTINUE TO COME.
HOW DO YOU MAKE IT STOP?
ESPECIALLY SINCE WE'RE HEARING
THAT THE CASES ARE NOW ON THE
RISE?
>> WE HAVE A MULTI-PART STRATEGY
IN THIS ADMINISTRATION.
THE VICE PRESIDENT IS LEADING AN
EFFORT TO ADDRESS THE ROOT
CAUSES IN THE SOURCE COUNTRIES
IN THE NORTHERN TRIANGLE,
GUATEMALA, HONHONDURAS, AND EL
SALVADOR, TO ASSIST THOSE
COUNTRIES IN BUILDING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE CAPACITY
SO PEOPLE DO NOT FEEL FORCED TO
FLEE THEIR HOMES.
WE ARE ADDRESSING THE HUMAN
SMUGGLERS AND, OF COURSE, WE ARE
PROVIDING FOR ASYLUM RELIEF FOR
THOSE WHO QUALIFY.
>> SECRETARY MAYORKAS, ONE OF
THE CONCERNS IS UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS AT THE BORDER BEING
ALLOWED TO STAY IN THIS COUNTRY.
THERE WAS A RECORD IN MARCH IN
TERMS OF CROSSINGS FROM THAT
GROUP.
WAS IT ALSO A RECORD?
AP
-- RECORD IN APRIL?
AND I DO SEE YOUR MESSAGE OF "DO
NOT COME" IS MAKING A
DIFFERENCE?
>> WE MADE A VERY IMPORTANT
DECISION THAT WE WOULD NOT
CONTINUE TO EXPEL UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN AS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DID.
IN LATE MARCH, ARE YOU CORRECT,
THE NUMBERS WERE EXTRAORDINARILY
HIGH.
WE HAD OVER 5,700 YOUNG CHILDREN
UNACCOMPANIED IN THE CUSTODY OF
THE BORDER PATROL.
NOW AS OF YESTERDAY, WE HAD
UNDER 700.
IT'S AN EXTRAORDINARY
ACHIEVEMENT, AND IT SPEAKS OF
THE COMMITMENT AND CAPABILITIES
OF THE MEN AND WOMEN AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
AND THE TEAMWORK WITH HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES.
>> BUT DOES --
>> WE ARE ADDRESSING THE NEEDS
OF CHILDREN.
>> DOES THAT REFLECT A REDUCTION
IN THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE COMING
OVER THE BORDER, OR JUST AN
INCREASE IN HOW QUICKLY YOU CAN
MOVE PEOPLE OUT OF YOUR CUSTODY
INTO HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES'
CUSTODY AND THEN TO SPONSORS?
>> WE DON'T HAVE THE APRIL
NUMBERS YET.
WE SHOULD HAVE THOSE
CUMULATIVELY WITHIN A DAY OR
TWO.
THE NUMBERS REMAIN HIGH, WHETHER
THEY ARE AS HIGH AS MARCH IS YET
UNDETERMINED.
BUT IT REALLY SPEAKS TO THE
REENGINEERING AND
OPERATIONALIZING OF THE PROCESS.
I SAID IN MARCH THAT WE HAVE A
PLAN, WE'RE EXECUTING ON THE
PLAN, AND THAT IT TAKES TIME.
WE ARE SEEING THOSE RESULTS IN
JUST 30 DAYS.
>> WE'RE HEARING THAT THERE'S
GOOD NEWS FROM YOUR DEPARTMENT
THIS MORNING, THAT -- YOU ALL
HAVE REUNITED FOUR FAMILIES --
FOUR CHILDREN, RATHER, WHO WERE
SEPARATED FROM THEIR FAMILIES
UNDER THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> THAT IS INDEED TRUE.
WE EXPECT FOUR FAMILIES TO BE
REUNITED TOMORROW.
>> HOW WERE YOU ABLE TO GET THEM
TOGETHER?
>> TWO OF THOSE FAMILIES --
>> THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT.
>> SO THIS IS THE WORK OF, ONCE
AGAIN, THE EXTRAORDINARY
COMMITMENT IN AN ALL OF
GOVERNMENT EFFORT FOLLOWING THE
PRESIDENT'S CHARGE THAT THIS IS
A PRIORITY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID WE MUST
REUNITE THESE FAMILIES.
HE DIRECTED THE CREATION OF A
TASK FORCE OF MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES IN AN
ALL OF GOVERNMENT EFFORT.
WE ARE WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION THAT HAS BEEN REPRESENTING
THE FAMILIES SINCE ITS INCEPTON
AND OTHER COMMUNITY-BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT AN ALL-IN
PUBLIC/PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP TO
REUNITE THE FAMILIES AND BEGIN
THE HEALING.
VERY PROUD --
>> THAT'S FOUR KIDS.
HOW MANY MORE ARE LEFT -- HOW
MUCH MORE ARE LEFT, SECRETARY,
AND THEN WE'VE GOT TO GO.
I'M GLAD WE'RE MAKING PROGRESS
ON THIS.
HOW MANY KIDS LEFT?
THE.
>> WE HAVE HUNDREDS LEFT.
WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF FAMILIES
LEFT, AND WE WILL REUNITE THEM